[SPEAKER_05]: So, I think mababig.
[SPEAKER_05]: Baka siguro yung matutuwangan ng video, dahil hindi na ako lang ng mga kanina yung more than, at least 50% of their personnel allowed na work for work.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yal natin diba, yun ako din sila, ipinalize sila ng mga pesa ng mga ano, na ako, dapat mula, more than 10% or something.
[SPEAKER_05]: At least paro na rin sa ano, sa mga pesa.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kaya baka kanong na yung work from home?
Alam pa kaya, maximum 3 days a week dapat na sa office or spot.
So 2 days yung pwede silang work from home.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero kung kailangan na ma-sa office o na spot.
[SPEAKER_09]: So kayo na, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano naman?
[SPEAKER_09]: Susunod yung from our tax.
[SPEAKER_09]: We can discuss muna yung ka-audit.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pwede na?
[SPEAKER_09]: We can start?
[SPEAKER_09]: No?
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, nakatayo kami ni Judd sakit.
[SPEAKER_09]: Hindi, kasi dapat, oo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Three hours na nag-aano eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: May planning meeting kami din.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ah, okay.
[SPEAKER_09]: Dali akong nakikinig.
Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: Okay, so good afternoon.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, we're here for the planning meeting for the 24th of August.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ang binis ng panahon lang.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Kaya nga i-insisted naman gano'y face-to-face tayo kasi last year wala tayong meeting.
[SPEAKER_09]: No, nagplanin din yata tayo.
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wala.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ano ko na plan?
[SPEAKER_09]: Nagplanin tayo yung closing ang ritual or wala na?
[SPEAKER_05]: Wala, wala.
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala yung closing.
[SPEAKER_09]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: Diretso na tayo.
[SPEAKER_09]: So for this year, I think ano?
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano nga bang change?
[SPEAKER_09]: As far as yung...
[SPEAKER_09]: Yeah, si Chad.
[SPEAKER_09]: He's the manager and si Janan yung senior associate.
[SPEAKER_09]: Si Jan, si Ferdy will be... Ay, alig ka anong Mike.
[SPEAKER_09]: Si Mike is a partner from Ertax.
[SPEAKER_09]: Afternoon.
[SPEAKER_09]: And Cheds and si Eileen.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ah, Angelo is my senior partner.
[SPEAKER_09]: Si Angelo pala.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sige, mamaya na.
[SPEAKER_02]: Galing din sa lunch eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi galing din sa lunch pero ayaw na yan.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: Tumayo.
[SPEAKER_09]: So I think ito naman for the roles and responsibilities.
[SPEAKER_09]: We have been observing this.
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala namang change, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: I think as far as your accounting framework, you will still fall under SMT.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige, next slide.
[SPEAKER_09]: So for the deliverables, same with last year, our primary deliverable will be the audit report.
[SPEAKER_09]: And then in relation to the requirements of BAR and SEC,
[SPEAKER_09]: In relation to the audited financial statement, so we also cover them.
[SPEAKER_09]: First, yung requirement TBIR na with regards to the taxes paid, so we cover that with our audit report.
[SPEAKER_09]: And then on the supplementary schedules required by the SEC, we also cover that.
[SPEAKER_09]: And then in the course of our audit, if we note items that will be for improvement of your processes and controls, so we also discussed that will be.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then for the terms of our audit, engagement, that will be summarized in the general engagement.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm just a distract.
[SPEAKER_06]: Actually kanina.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nung pumasok.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nung pumasok pa rin.
[SPEAKER_02]: Narinig ko na siya.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aircon n'ya, tamang daras.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aircon.
[SPEAKER_06]: Hindi naman sila separate naman sila, no?
[SPEAKER_06]: Tawagan naman si Ate.
[SPEAKER_06]: Daba't distract.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sorry ah.
[SPEAKER_09]: O nga eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pagpasok po din kanina eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano yan?
[SPEAKER_09]: Kalimbang.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ay sinabalawa talaga lumabas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano naman ito mga bata nito?
[SPEAKER_01]: Hindi naman sila?
[SPEAKER_01]: Tata lang, hindi naman si Andre.
[SPEAKER_01]: Teamwork.
[SPEAKER_01]: Teamwork, teamwork.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano naman?
[SPEAKER_07]: Iwala naku.
[SPEAKER_09]: So actually, just to ask for updates, meron bang anything, any changes in the operations compared to prior year as far as sa organization, number of personnel?
[SPEAKER_09]: More or less the same naman.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi lumabas kayong dalo mo.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano kasi isa lang?
[SPEAKER_09]: So wala naman, related party transactions.
[SPEAKER_06]: Wala na related parties.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sinapos mo na.
[SPEAKER_06]: Mag-debate nga sana kami!
[SPEAKER_06]: Wala, nasa U.S.
[SPEAKER_06]: na siya.
[SPEAKER_09]: Hanggang February pa kaya okay ka.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kaya relaxed ako.
[SPEAKER_09]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_09]: Nakikiriyensap.
[SPEAKER_09]: Talaga?
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano siya ngayon?
[SPEAKER_09]: May inaano kasi siya pero yung about charter.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero hindi na rin interested yung dating tao na interested.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero hindi na rin siya umano-kinanuel eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ah, okay.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, magano.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, as far as alo ba, in general, kungusta yung volume of transactions?
[SPEAKER_09]: We're closer to the 2019 levels.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, nandob pa lang kami as far as the volume is concerned.
[SPEAKER_09]: Although, anong impact sa inyo?
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi sa corporates, parang generally, nabawasan talaga parang nag-shift na to virtual eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Naalala ko dati, every 5 years, kung punta kami Singapore ngayon wala.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hindi, ano yan?
[SPEAKER_07]: Meeting set event, sin-send event.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano yun?
[SPEAKER_09]: Sa iba talaga, it's ano no?
[SPEAKER_09]: It's still ongoing.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pati yung mga law firms are actually still... Kami?
[SPEAKER_01]: Kami naman talaga loka lang eh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Never pa kami nag-out of the box.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ikaw nga na-experience ang ACB eh, yung Singapore eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ah, talaga?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, ooo!
[SPEAKER_01]: Hindi pa ako partner ng last na... Ako na ka dalawa.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi usually, pag nag-change ng global chairman, lagaano siya.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ah, that's new.
[SPEAKER_09]: Oh, so... Getting to know.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, ano?
[SPEAKER_09]: Si sino yun?
[SPEAKER_09]: Si Berga.
[SPEAKER_09]: Dalawa.
[SPEAKER_09]: Tapos ito nga yung girl yung aming global, si MP.
[SPEAKER_09]: Si Marin Janet.
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala.
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala siyang ano... Emo ko ano planet niya.
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka naman, one year later.
[SPEAKER_07]: Baka ma-restore.
[SPEAKER_07]: And then kasi yung ibang ginagawa nila, parang pagkunyari junior partner, local, tapos pag yung... ano yan yung... hindi sa execom, senior, parang Asia, and then yung pinaka-global, yun yung international.
[SPEAKER_09]: Parang mga... Actually, dati sa undersend ninyo.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung pupunta ng yung mga senior-senior lang.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero nung nag-hearn sa niyang kasi, lahat, ano sila eh, ngayon wala talaga.
[SPEAKER_07]: Wala, wala.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hopefully next year, malaga din.
[SPEAKER_07]: Actually, yun nga, depende sa industry like pharma.
[SPEAKER_07]: Actually, pharma hindi masyado.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's more of law firms, BPO's, manufacturing.
[SPEAKER_09]: No firms, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero ngayon sila.
Out of the country ang sila rin.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige lang kami, lo ka lang talaga.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala naman mga one-off na contracts?
[SPEAKER_09]: Like sa offices mo and in major, capex?
Wala.
Wala naman.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ang mga recurring naman eh, hindi mga, hindi tawil naman mga firewall, mga firewall, mga site, tapos licenses, so... Ano na nga ba ang ano nyo sa IT?
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung accounting records nyo, ano yung register?
[SPEAKER_09]: Nakat-cast na ba?
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala, nandito.
[SPEAKER_09]: So it's loose-leaf pa lang.
[SPEAKER_09]: Mabilis na ngayon oh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sabi?
[SPEAKER_09]: Dati hindi...
[SPEAKER_09]: Oo, mabilis na sila ngayon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hindi katulad na... Average 6 months na.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now yun, there's one special team ng D.I.R.
[SPEAKER_05]: o kad R.D.O.?
[SPEAKER_01]: Normally sa national kasi to doon sa national team.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos meron silang dedicated team doon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Although some naman, nat-train na rin nila siguro kaya rin naging mas mabilis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos nawala na rin kasi yung, before kasi before ka-issue nang permit, kailangan ng testing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ngayon, yung testing will be done post-audit.
[SPEAKER_01]: So issue muna nila yung what they call acknowledgement certificate tapos nakalagay lang doon may nakalagay na statement na you will be subjected to post audit.
[SPEAKER_05]: So at the time of post audit, di ka pala compliant doon sa requirements, yun nga lang may deficiency, may penalties and na pwedeng iimpose.
[SPEAKER_05]: Saan namin makikita sa website ba nila ang...
[SPEAKER_05]: I can share that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can share.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll share through the link.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yan kasi the last year sabi niya ang hirap-hirap eh.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sabi mo, diba?
[SPEAKER_01]: Years na or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wala pa mag-prove.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ngayon kasi with the OPT.
[SPEAKER_01]: yung Isopin Taxes Act really this year tapos continuous kasi sila na they're saying they would like to digitalize.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nakita rin naman namin in terms of the process.
[SPEAKER_01]: Average of 6 months provided na mabigay naman yung mga documents na required for the application.
[SPEAKER_07]: Meron ba kayong client, yung mga tag-apply na naman?
[SPEAKER_07]: Marami ba yung male deficiency?
[SPEAKER_01]: Hindi naman.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mix actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meron yung talaga kasing detaliado.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tinig na nila maiging muna yung document sila before actually filing.
[SPEAKER_01]: To sum it, yung iba nai-involve kami kung baka parang nireview muna namin, then before the actual application.
[SPEAKER_01]: At the time of the application, ano na?
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang halos cleared na lahat kasi we do parang informal checking with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kung mayroon mga peculiarity dun sa client, sa industry ng client, chini-check namin in advance.
[SPEAKER_01]: Para once na nagsubmit kami sa kanila, ano na?
[SPEAKER_01]: At least parang na pre-clear na kumbaga.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos more on formality na lang yung pag-assion acknowledgement certificate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ang pinabantayan lang namin kasi nakita namin sa mga BIR audit, nagkakaroon ng mismatch.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ito yung in-apply.
[SPEAKER_01]: si isampong dokumentong nakalagay doon na i-generate ng system.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paglabas ng acknowledgement certificate o yung permit itself, walong na lang yung nakalagay.
[SPEAKER_01]: E, syempre ikaw, all this time you know na in-apply mo yan eh.
[SPEAKER_01]: So supposedly the permit should show the complete set.
[SPEAKER_01]: But for some reason, hindi nagmamatch, hindi na-check.
[SPEAKER_01]: E, na-post audit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nagkaroon tulay ng penalties.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the penalties kasi, at least yung nakita namin, 1,000 per document.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eh kung meron kaming na-experience, andami, libo rin yung document na na-issue.
[SPEAKER_01]: E di umabag din ang million yung penalty.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yun yung nire-remind namin sa audit clients namin and other clients na kung sa kaling may application, although mabilis yung proseso, make sure nabanga yung application dun sa acknowledgement certificate.
[SPEAKER_07]: That's all the details dapat nandoon sa document.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pero yung acknowledgement certificate is issued way after
[SPEAKER_01]: Within the span of 6 months.
[SPEAKER_05]: Meron mas mabilis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meron mas mabilis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merong it takes time lalo na kung merong deficiencies sa documents.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nagbabak-import kasi.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sabi nila ang medyo nakita namin in our experience na medyo nagkaroon ng difficulty yung ibang kliente.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung mga IT related documents yung may mga specification talaga as to the technicalities of the system.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kasi they would like to ensure na yung
[SPEAKER_01]: Nige-generate ng system will be compliant, at least on a high level compliant doon sa requirement signal.
[SPEAKER_01]: And mayroon na rin pag mag-apply na travel agencies?
[SPEAKER_01]: Travel agency?
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang wala pa akong nananood na travel agency.
[SPEAKER_01]: Service...
[SPEAKER_07]: Service-oriented taxpayers, medyo marami na.
[SPEAKER_07]: But specifically to travel agencies, wala.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi nga walang gusto mag-file dahil nga, pinapakreate nila ako ng tax position paper na dudalan ko kay ano.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi nga, walang, hindi baka ka-comply yung cast namin kung hindi paklear nung taxation, nung ibang issue eh.
[SPEAKER_07]: May mga issues kami eh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ang siguro critical to note lang is yung lalo nalikong yung mga large taxpayers kasi na tax, ah yun ya, in terms of classification kasi sila required.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ang required kasi as of now, strictly speaking, under the law, those that are under the large taxpayers office, those na engage sa exports, sale of goods and services, and those that are engaged in e-commerce.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yun yung tatlo right now but we're hearing na if you have
[SPEAKER_01]: transactions with large taxpayers, eventually you will be required.
[SPEAKER_01]: So sa atin, ako, for sure Philippine Airlines is one of the large taxpayers.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're dealing with airlines.
[SPEAKER_01]: So ano yan?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think even Cebu Pacific is a large taxpayer.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if that direction will happen soon, makokcover tayo.
[SPEAKER_01]: So something to look out for siguro down there.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cross-reference talaga sila.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung i-invoicing kasi yung ano tayo natin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gusto nila.
[SPEAKER_01]: And pinupush din kasi sila, even sa mga conventions, conferences outside the Philippines.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung parang we are saying talaga na we're moving towards digitalization.
[SPEAKER_09]: So that's part of it.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: So for regulatory, compliance and regulations, may ano pa ang bumi?
[SPEAKER_09]: Examination.
[SPEAKER_09]: For 2021?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oo, mayroon.
[SPEAKER_09]: For 2023.
[SPEAKER_09]: Bilis, sarapan.
Later.
Siyempre.
Kailangan nila eh.
Nang fans.
[SPEAKER_04]: Pero nasa ano pala naman?
[SPEAKER_04]: Examination?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oo.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wala pa?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oo, wala pa.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
Legal cases.
[SPEAKER_05]: May sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa... sa
[SPEAKER_05]: na based sa compromise na lang kasi hindi naman talaga na-examine na arbitrary na lang na.
[SPEAKER_05]: Naka-buro pa sa no, sa CIR.
Ilang ano na?
[SPEAKER_09]: When was the last communication?
[SPEAKER_09]: 2022 man natin?
[SPEAKER_09]: Last year.
[SPEAKER_09]: Last year may ano.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige, so...
[SPEAKER_09]: So we just showed here yung late test niyo na available.
[SPEAKER_09]: In terms of ano naman, it looks mas mataasa nga, in terms of P&L, mas mataas yung siguro yung cost lang, there might be some cost, operating cost that needs to be reclassified to their cost.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kapital wala namang change.
[SPEAKER_05]: Still the same yung ano.
[SPEAKER_09]: So there are a few items lang that we want to discuss with you as early as now.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ito yung CWT kasi lumalaki ito eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: So I don't know how much will be added this year, but based on the three-year trend, malaki talaga yung nadadagdag sa kanya.
[SPEAKER_09]: So what's critical is, of course the classification, is to estimate how much is
[SPEAKER_09]: estimated to be applied against the tax due for the year and then reclassify the rest to a non-inferent portion and yun nga talaga what is the plan kasi for financial reporting kasi if you will not tumataas siya and if we go back lang sa balance sheet so nandiyan siya part of the
[SPEAKER_09]: I think may portion na nasa non-current.
[SPEAKER_09]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_09]: So that's 30-something million of the 200.
[SPEAKER_09]: So lumalaki siya eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pag hindi kasi siya nagagamit in the foreseeable future, there might be a need to make provision kung wala kayong planong
[SPEAKER_09]: ...di-apply for refund, which is alam naman natin, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: So siguro the only way to realize that is to really make... ...income.
[SPEAKER_09]: But at the same time, ma-address yung... I think kaya siya malaki, diba?
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi may nag-withhold sa inyo.
[SPEAKER_07]: Na dapat hindi, diba?
[SPEAKER_07]: Actually, it's credit card, diba?
[SPEAKER_07]: It's more of credit card payments, yung reimburseable.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi nga ang withholding then is one half of one percent of the entire amount.
[SPEAKER_09]: Dapat service fee lang din namin, kung saan nag-we withhold.
[SPEAKER_09]: But then, that's the rule for credit cards talaga eh, is one half of one percent eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Buti niya lang mababay rate baka eh kung hindi ba mababay.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kaya lang nga eh, nahihit talaga sila cash flow wise.
[SPEAKER_04]: Na natatrap eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Natatrap 36 na.
[SPEAKER_09]: We don't know baka
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka this year, ano?
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka 40 na yan.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yan yung problema, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi that should have been cash.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ang tanong, ano yung timing ng collection?
[SPEAKER_09]: Kung sa ano pa yan?
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka kung receivable yan, baka doubtful na.
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka may portion dyan na doubtful, not because hindi siya
[SPEAKER_09]: Hindi siya, how do you call that?
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano naman siya na may support ka ba?
[SPEAKER_09]: Kung receivable, collectible ba yan?
[SPEAKER_09]: Magagamit ba natin yan?
[SPEAKER_09]: When?
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi yung realizability minsan, you have to take into account the time value of money.
Parang ganoon eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, that's something that we may want to check.
[SPEAKER_01]: especially na lumalaki na talaga siya.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, BIR naman, provided na it's properly supported, wala naman issue.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, for accounting purposes, there's a need to check ngayon for realizability.
[SPEAKER_01]: But for BIR naman, provided na it's properly supported and recognized in the ITR, wala naman concern sa site natin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano lang?
[SPEAKER_09]: Sa financial reporting lang eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Well, for tax talaga, if you don't see na maggamit niyo siya, magano ko talaga, you will have to buy the book.
[SPEAKER_09]: Depende, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: Kung kaya niyo mag-apply for refund.
[SPEAKER_09]: But for financial reporting, ano talaga niya?
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka dapat iyan na siya.
[SPEAKER_09]: Magpaprovide ka ng allowance.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi nga, you don't see na magagamit mo siya in the next so many years.
[SPEAKER_09]: But if something ano na magagamit ko siya, you can always reverse naman ng allowance.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero kung ang tax, nandyan lang yan.
[SPEAKER_09]: It's yours, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: Yun lang.
[SPEAKER_09]: Iba kasi ang financial reporting and tax reporting.
Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero hopefully, may magagawa doon sa dapat ang withholdan lang.
[SPEAKER_09]: Or kahit withholdan kayo, dapat na kahiwalay sa credit card.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi nga, yung income nyo talaga, it's just a small portion of the total.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige, nice.
[SPEAKER_09]: So ito naman, of course, the adequacy of the allowance for the full account.
[SPEAKER_09]: So every year naman, you do this.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pitingnan lang yung aging and then assess the connectivity.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: So we just indicated there.
[SPEAKER_09]: Actually dito, we requested sana na interim.
[SPEAKER_09]: Is this something visible sa inyo?
[SPEAKER_09]: Sa... We will look at this sana at in the ring like based on the October 31.
[SPEAKER_09]: If ano na yung October 31.
[SPEAKER_09]: So malamang...
[SPEAKER_05]: Your end na lang.
[SPEAKER_05]: Malit lang ba ang receivable?
[SPEAKER_05]: Actually, kasi nga walang receivable, halos nila ang credit card.
[SPEAKER_05]: Walang masyado eh.
[SPEAKER_05]: So yun lang yung manualy billed lang.
Yung rule checks ng mga clients.
[SPEAKER_09]: So ito naman, ito din yung for the certain long outstanding liabilities siguro part of the exercise din lang when you close the books is to check if these are still valid liabilities.
[SPEAKER_07]: Minanood lang kami in prior years na... But of course, I think some of these are legitimate, ano naman, you know, deposits kasi they are still your customers.
[SPEAKER_05]: May naiimog ba dyan mula pandemic?
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi yung di ba credit lang naman?
[SPEAKER_07]: Meron pa, yung mga... Yung mga ibang nag-detain ng inside.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yung kasi nandang cancer, yung pandemic, yung galang yun.
[SPEAKER_09]: We just have to wait for the parang end period yung mga viability ng mga... Okay, I think... yun lang naman, no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Unless... Do you have any, ano?
[SPEAKER_05]: You feel na baka... kailangan natin, ano?
[SPEAKER_05]: The address?
[SPEAKER_05]: Wala naman.
[SPEAKER_05]: Except for yung...
[SPEAKER_09]: Kaya hinintay ko sila yung press natin.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ang dami kasi, ano?
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige, so anyway, so these are the required inquiries na for management that we just need to inquire from you.
[SPEAKER_09]: So first would be on fraud, meron bang anything that was reported during the year or anything that we also need to address during our audit.
[SPEAKER_09]: Compliance with laws and regulations?
[SPEAKER_09]: I think DIR lang naman yung ano?
[SPEAKER_09]: Related parties?
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala naman.
[SPEAKER_09]: Going concerns?
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala naman tayo.
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala naman tayong plans.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: Independence?
[SPEAKER_09]: I think of it by just cyber.
[SPEAKER_09]: Anything na may mga attempts to ano?
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung mga, marami lang mga emails.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano yung mga phishing?
[SPEAKER_09]: Oo yung mga ganoon.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero nothing.
[SPEAKER_09]: G-cash?
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala ba sa inyong na ano?
[SPEAKER_02]: Wala.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero we accept G-cash payments.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano na?
[SPEAKER_09]: Meron na?
Meron na?
[SPEAKER_09]: Meron
[SPEAKER_07]: Kung sa business niya yun, or personal.
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka naman kasi binigay niya yung mga security password niya kung kadi-ganun mo.
Sige, climate-related.
[SPEAKER_09]: I think wala naman si Enyo no, kasi be an agent wala naman.
[SPEAKER_09]: So it's really more of dun sa mga airlines.
[SPEAKER_09]: At least the topic of ano.
[SPEAKER_07]: climate change and sustainability na iba lang yung mga seasons nung iba kasi mas mahaban na yung winter or mahaban na yung mga ganyan o yung summer mas mahaban, depende sa lanina, elmino yung mga ganoon yun pala so yun ang ano yun ang effect noon tsaka yung storms, typhoons, cancellation of flights pero may BCP naman na yung case so wala kaming issue
[SPEAKER_07]: Meron pa kami na levels ng DCP.
[SPEAKER_09]: So kailangan.
[SPEAKER_09]: Adress naman.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero grabe nga din ang weather ngayon.
[SPEAKER_09]: Oo iba talaga.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero this year ba anong mahaba ba ang winter?
[SPEAKER_07]: Itong ngayon?
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano ba ngayon?
[SPEAKER_07]: Nandiniya?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yung winter mo yung mahaba.
[SPEAKER_06]: Makahagul.
[SPEAKER_06]: Baka may snow pa sa April.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ganoon na, joke.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano na lang, mafipil pa rin niya yung snow sa ibang parts of the country, yung mga mountain top, mga peaks, mga ski areas.
[SPEAKER_07]: Meron, korea.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ilang tao ka na?
[SPEAKER_07]: Hindi kasi, ages 18 to 35, maganda yung resort ng isang brad namin.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pasapakot.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kainis na lang.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano yun?
[SPEAKER_07]: Wala akong insight.
[SPEAKER_04]: O korea yun.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pane, Disney ka nalang, Disney ka nalang.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kaka-appoint lang namin eh.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sa Disney Cruise.
[SPEAKER_07]: In Singapore.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pane, year round siya pero kaming appointed.
Iyan.
[SPEAKER_06]: Ano ang gano'n?
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano ang gano'n?
Ano ang gano'n?
[SPEAKER_07]: Meron niyo mga princess something, mga ganoon niyo.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano talaga?
[SPEAKER_04]: Bata.
[SPEAKER_06]: Mag-enjoy mga bata.
[SPEAKER_06]: Pangit ako mag-beta, no?
[SPEAKER_06]: So mga bata, so mga bata isip.
[SPEAKER_06]: Magkano kaya?
[SPEAKER_06]: Ano ang mga ganoon niyan?
[SPEAKER_06]: Wala pa.
[SPEAKER_06]: Ano nalabas ba lang yung pricing?
[SPEAKER_07]: November?
[SPEAKER_07]: November 14 lalabas yung pricing.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pero you can only start selling December 10.
[SPEAKER_04]: O yung ano, cluster outing o ano yan?
[SPEAKER_04]: Ano na lang?
[SPEAKER_04]: Sa loob?
[SPEAKER_09]: Dibre na lahat.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yun ano, yung direct flight diba, ng Sibupak to Sapporo, diba?
[SPEAKER_09]: Nakakaroan na sila.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ang pala ba walang?
[SPEAKER_09]: Next year pa na.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ah, next year din.
[SPEAKER_07]: Client mo siya, no?
[SPEAKER_07]: Client mo siya ng SGC.
[SPEAKER_07]: Napapansin?
[SPEAKER_07]: Napapansin ko e. Su-su-su na mention.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sige, kasi ang dami ko gusto ng correct sa nila.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige, so eto naman, just to share, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: So we are
[SPEAKER_09]: Also slowly digitizing our audit.
[SPEAKER_09]: But of course, depende rin yun sa data na makukuha namin.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I think we have used... ano na no?
[SPEAKER_09]: And then...
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige, try.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ikaw ang mag-explain yan.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eto ang mga bata ang mag-explain yan.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yung sa Canvas and Client Portal lang po, we're going to continuously use lang pinpo to.
[SPEAKER_03]: So kindly expect na yung mga audit request put namin will be communicated still through the Canvas Client Portal and then for the automation process po.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yung isa po at talaga na hina-highlight naman dito is yung sa IWA intelligence checklist.
[SPEAKER_03]: So as early as interim, maybe we should revisit na po yung notes disclosure natin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yung e-way intelligence checklist ko would assist you on identifying what are the reward disclosures po dun sa LSP.
[SPEAKER_03]: So if there are any na wala pa po doon based din sa pagsabot po natin sa scoping ng e-way intelligence checklist ko, maybe we can add po.
[SPEAKER_09]: We could consider din po.
[SPEAKER_09]: Knowing na medyo strict na din po kasi mga regulations.
[SPEAKER_09]: Just to add, kasi si LSEC wala na siyang
[SPEAKER_09]: Wala na siyang oversight sa external auditor because of the Supreme Court ruling that was passed last year.
[SPEAKER_09]: So ang ginawan niya, this year, sinulatan niya selected companies and then nag-review sila ng financial statements and then may mga comments siya.
[SPEAKER_09]: So hindi lang listed ha.
[SPEAKER_09]: Parang iba-iba.
[SPEAKER_04]: So wala naman tayong nar-receive.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, yun lang.
[SPEAKER_09]: Let's prepare for that.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi, medyo, ano sila, madetalia din silang mag-review.
[SPEAKER_09]: At ang cash flow.
[SPEAKER_09]: Gusto nila lahat nakikita.
[SPEAKER_09]: Parang, hindi naman dapat nilalagay lahat sa notes, sa lahat ng movement.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero gusto nila, pinapa-explain lang nila.
[SPEAKER_09]: So yun, sa inyo yan isusulag.
[SPEAKER_09]: Dati kasi sa amin, direct show yun.
[SPEAKER_09]: So ngayon, sa company sila,
[SPEAKER_09]: Susula.
[SPEAKER_05]: But of course, we'll coordinate naman.
[SPEAKER_05]: So yun lang.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ang purpose nila.
[SPEAKER_05]: Parang dapat na yung committee o... Dapat ng compliance.
[SPEAKER_05]: Pagkala kung bakit sinaral na sila yun.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi wala na silang, sabi nila, hindi naman pwede wala kaming gagawin.
[SPEAKER_09]: So sige, sa companies tayo magsumula.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yun!
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi kami, board of accountancy na yung kanpo.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then for the analyzing part, so we will be utilizing the GL Analyzer.
[SPEAKER_03]: So more of, yung magiging basis naman po dito is yung data po mismo na ibibigay po ninyo, titignan lang po muna namin kung kaya ba namin siyang ilog dun sa analyzer po namin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Para medyo, kati na lang din po yung mga itatalong namin sa inyo.
[SPEAKER_03]: Especially when it comes to moments of the accounts, you will be able to better analyze your data using this tool.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then for the next days po, we are targeting also to continuously adding mga iwan yung tos.
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka kung meron ba dito na pwede nating indigitalize na to ensure na hindi na gano'n kadami or ano po yung naralagas po naman sa iso.
[SPEAKER_09]: Is it sa analyzer na yan?
[SPEAKER_09]: Ibig sabihin may AI na kayo or it's a static tool?
[SPEAKER_09]: Right now, well, meron na kami pero hindi pa.
[SPEAKER_09]: Hindi pa siya nakaintegrate.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kami pa rin yung bibigyan lang kami ng reports and then we will analyze.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero meron na.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero hindi pa siya na ano dyan.
[SPEAKER_09]: Meron na kaming sarili namin, Chart GPT.
[SPEAKER_09]: So pag nalano kami, pag nag-research, mas dapat doon kami mag-research kasi mas reliable nung mga links.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung saan kasi Chart GPT kung saan-saan.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kung saan-saan kumukuha.
[SPEAKER_09]: Siyempre.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung lang available sa kanilang.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_09]: If we have the data, siguro, tapos kanunod namin to sa JL Analyzing Board, we can show you some of the reports naman, especially if we have questions.
[SPEAKER_09]: We'll further coordinate na lang, further coordinate.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sino ba ang point person sa ano nga yung ginagamit niyo na tropical?
[SPEAKER_02]: Ako po at sya ako si Loida.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kami pa rin, ma'am.
[SPEAKER_03]: But we're currently presenting also yung proposal of the time period.
[SPEAKER_03]: No significant changes naman pa hades from the prior year po.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we're not yet lang po na at least lang sana for this year, we're going to be able to finish yung update on the understanding of the key processes po, natin sa FSM.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then early January also, we will be requesting also yung travel plans po and German entries from the prior year.
[SPEAKER_03]: Kayo ba yan?
[SPEAKER_03]: Kayo po ba yun?
[SPEAKER_09]: Parang kakabalik lang nila niyan sa bahasyon eh.
[SPEAKER_06]: Isaman niyo ko kami.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga... Kaso ko lang sa mga
[SPEAKER_03]: Sa karamihan?
[SPEAKER_07]: Apo.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pagmarch kasi.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oo.
[SPEAKER_07]: Mga, anong big po ngayon na Feb you are?
[SPEAKER_05]: Kaya.
[SPEAKER_05]: Third.
[SPEAKER_07]: Third daw.
[SPEAKER_06]: Olod daw.
[SPEAKER_09]: Eh, tatlo lang ang weeks sa Feb, baby.
[SPEAKER_09]: O agangan natin.
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka lang makarami.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige, ma'am.
[SPEAKER_09]: Try.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ha?
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi pag... Yung mga last week of Feb, parang march na yan eh.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano na yan?
[SPEAKER_07]: Magkulo na tayo niyan.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hindi, sorry.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pwede naman kayong... Kailangan ba altogether niyo i-submit?
[SPEAKER_02]: O ano yung i-endine lang?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yung books kasi, mame, in the ending kung ano yung... At least siguro ano priorities po yung income statement account list po na hindi ka yun din ba?
[SPEAKER_04]: Especially we're considering obviously science, art, and engineering.
[SPEAKER_09]: Daya timeline na, may kumag-copy mo na kayo.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sige ba, ano nalang coffee or may non-copy na kayo kuya?
[SPEAKER_07]: May iced tea.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sige ako din iced tea.
[SPEAKER_07]: Para mabilis.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sigurang for list mo na nandin po.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung sa confirmation letters po, naminitang po natin, that is by December.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ano bang muntagang natin banks at saka?
[SPEAKER_05]: Hindi namin control kasi, tapos yung direction na kasi sa inyo.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ang ginagawa mo ng banks, ang ginagawa namin niyo, nag-mail kami ba, we also send email kung sino yun sa amin.
[SPEAKER_09]: May size bagon, sen.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero kami lang, bigyan niyo lang kami ng contact name.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pero ang same format pa rin bang ano?
[SPEAKER_05]: Pag-affirmation.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wala naman po so far na bago.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tapos siguro po if you have din yung number, pwede po namin tawagan din nito.
[SPEAKER_09]: So yan muna na lang.
[SPEAKER_09]: We'll closely coordinate na lang po din sa penguin.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung sa course eh... Sige.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ano na din no?
Yung letter?
[SPEAKER_03]: Apo, by and... Sabay na lang.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sigur-sigur.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hindi, mapilis sila.
[SPEAKER_05]: Korsek.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yun ang format na gusto nila eh, ang certification.
[SPEAKER_03]: Naman na susundan din eh ng Korsek.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, one more na lang yun na?
[SPEAKER_03]: Para isahan na lang.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bani lahat po ng request ko.
[SPEAKER_03]: Kung kaya po natin mag-refer na po ng December, para send na lang talaga naman.
[SPEAKER_03]: assignment po kayo.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you po.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then yung last po would be yung sa year end or the time diwala man po.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, um, since February po, so we'll expect na lang po na yun.
[SPEAKER_03]: And since February, so we'll expect na lang po na yun.
[SPEAKER_03]: And since February, so we'll expect na
[SPEAKER_03]: maaahina po para step po.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung sa notes po, we can check that as rin niya sintering po.
[SPEAKER_09]: Especially if wala naman po change halos dun saanin.
[SPEAKER_09]: Business.
[SPEAKER_09]: Ok na kayo so far dun saan na, thank you.
[SPEAKER_09]: Or do you have any comments mo?
[SPEAKER_04]: Balik ka nalang sa internet.
We'll check din, no?
Once, okay naman yan, no?
[SPEAKER_09]: November 15 yung October.
[SPEAKER_09]: Or September.
[SPEAKER_09]: Mayroon na mo na.
[SPEAKER_02]: Baka we can use na muna.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kailan kayo nagsasarado ng Oktober?
Ong going pa tayo na Oktober, mami.
[SPEAKER_02]: Baka mga... Ano ba?
[SPEAKER_04]: Maka-week?
[SPEAKER_07]: Opo, mamikas.
[SPEAKER_02]: October 4?
[SPEAKER_07]: Opo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, opo.
[SPEAKER_02]: E, siyempre mag-aayos pa tayo.
[SPEAKER_02]: So mga last week po siguro ng November or to first week of December.
[SPEAKER_09]: Sige, baka ending October.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi, we will plan, let's plan to do some procedures now, Kindly.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi mag-aangkabal.
[SPEAKER_09]: At least wala ang isiguro, analize yun ang dina-dita ng lima siya.
Para bigalot namin ang dina-dita ng pasti niya.
[SPEAKER_03]: And so we have highlighted lang dito dito yung critical audit requirements na we want with the program in High School.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, as discussed po for the mentors, we expect naka-prepare na po siya by December.
[SPEAKER_09]: And then, yung mga kinilig din po kanunang, din sa areas of audit lang pa rin ko, so nunginigin ko yung chat na rin ko yung sa adikmasin niyo pa alam, as far as that one comes.
[SPEAKER_09]: Per December na nang niligagaw.
[SPEAKER_09]: Year end.
[SPEAKER_09]: Siguro yung anong, yung journal entries na baka dapat,
[SPEAKER_09]: September na.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kasi kung mag-October wala na, januari na nila mabibigay yan.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sige, sige po.
[SPEAKER_09]: Paka-September na din para maibigay this month hopefully.
[SPEAKER_09]: If na close na naman po, nabigay na po kasi yung try and balance per September.
[SPEAKER_09]: So kung sakali po baka pahabol na lang din po na sa journal entries po.
[SPEAKER_09]: Journal entries.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nahingi na natin yan last year.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alam na nila yun?
[SPEAKER_09]: Yung disability spot na hindi ka?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes po, na hindi ka.
[SPEAKER_03]: Pero hindi ka?
[SPEAKER_03]: TV pa lang buobos yun na.
[SPEAKER_03]: So nandiscast na sa kanila, how to go about it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yung mga fields po na required.
[SPEAKER_03]: Magkokomunicate pa rin pa rin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ano hindi nyo?
[SPEAKER_03]: Otherwise hindi nila yan ma-extract.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sige pa, mag-communicate na lang po kami para ma-check din pa kung kayong i-load po din sa tool po namin.
[SPEAKER_09]: May ano pa kayo?
[SPEAKER_09]: May IT person naman kayo.
[SPEAKER_09]: Isama niyo yung IT person siguro?
[SPEAKER_09]: For anong purpose?
[SPEAKER_09]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yung pag-extract ng data?
[SPEAKER_07]: Ah, iba kasi yung IT namin.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, po.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi siya IT.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, yung sa GL.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yung sa GL.
[SPEAKER_03]: Pero kung kaya niyo.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sila yun.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi pag successful kasi tayo na makuha namin yung data at hindi na kami hihingi ng marami schedule kasi from that data kaya na niyang... kasi yung program kung saan namin siya ilagay, EY ano naman yun, kaya niyang mag-generate o information.
[SPEAKER_09]: But yun nga, it depends kasi if the data is clean, kaya niya.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pag medyo maraming mga manual adjustment yun, medyo na ano siya.
[SPEAKER_09]: So the earlier na makuha namin, the earlier din natin malalaman.
[SPEAKER_09]: And hopefully mag-work siya para konti na lang ihingi namin sa annual schedule.
[SPEAKER_09]: So i think mag-tax update mo na.
[SPEAKER_01]: General ano lang naman, we've been extra busy, the tax team is extra busy nowadays because of several issues.
[SPEAKER_01]: including new loss this year.
[SPEAKER_01]: It started with the Issa Paying Taxes Act early this year.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hopefully, it really eases the tax compliance requirements.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then it followed by a Real Property Validation Act.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then last month, the VAT on digital services.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then just yesterday, we had the Create More.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's four major losses this year in between
[SPEAKER_01]: there were several issuances from the Bureau of Eternal Revenue.
[SPEAKER_01]: So allow me to present some of the highlights or salient provisions of these issuances and all.
[SPEAKER_01]: So allow me to start with the ISO Paying Taxes Act.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is a slide summarizing the relevant dates.
[SPEAKER_01]: So early this year, this one took effect January 22, then the implementing rules and regulations
[SPEAKER_01]: were issued last April.
[SPEAKER_01]: So in terms of the effectivity, it's April 27, 2024.
[SPEAKER_01]: So unless otherwise stated, the new invoicing requirements specifically, it applies to April 27 transactions onwards.
[SPEAKER_01]: So in the subsequent slide, we noted that one of the most significant updates or amendments introduced by AOPT, which pertains to the streamlining of reporting.
[SPEAKER_01]: So whether you're a seller of goods, services, or lesser of properties, the timing of reporting will be at the time of sale as evidenced by a BET invoice.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the basis will be gross sales.
[SPEAKER_01]: Before I understand, if you report BET, it's based on collection.
[SPEAKER_01]: But with EOPT, it should now be based on your sales.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, there are allowable deductions such as sales discounts, sales allowances, subject to certain conditions.
[SPEAKER_01]: So in view of the change in the timing of reporting for BAT purposes in the subsequent slide, we presented a mechanism introduced by AOBT.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically, if ever that you have accounts receivable and such receivable was not collected within the due date or within the payment term or credit term, you have an option to actually reduce your output BAT on the transaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: So again, this is merely an option.
[SPEAKER_01]: on your part as a seller or even on the part of your suppliers.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, for instance, you have a receivable, say, this quarter, it's already Q4, and the credit term is, say, it will fall in Q1 next year.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, in the following quarter, Q2, in this particular illustration, you will be allowed to claim that as a reduction in your VAT reporting.
[SPEAKER_01]: So again, but again this is merely an option especially since there are requirements to be complied with and it includes a closely close monitoring of the status of your receivables.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if you believe that there is high likelihood that you will be able to collect the receivables then there's no need for you to avail of this mechanism.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's also possible from the side of your suppliers that they will avail of this option
[SPEAKER_01]: So if that will be the case, they have to issue a document to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that document will include a stamp statement saying that they actually claim output BAT credit on the transaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: So in your side, you have to adjust your input BAT.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it applies to you as a seller, but if in case that there's really a high likelihood that you will be able to collect, then there's no need
[SPEAKER_01]: for you to adjust but on the part of your supplier they also have that option in the subsequent slide this one this is just a summary of the updated invoicing requirements prior to april 27 if the transaction happened prior to april 27 but official receipt that's the documentation but april 27 onwards it should be
[SPEAKER_01]: date invoice or what we call transitory invoice so i'm sure you've seen some documents say official receipt or bill of statement you strike through the words uh official receipt or bill of statement then you stamp the word invoice or similar wordings that will be the support for
[SPEAKER_01]: sa transaction, sa input ng VAT sa transaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: It also applies to you as a seller of service.
[SPEAKER_01]: So in your case, before you're issuing official receipt, you are now required to issue VAT invoice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you already have?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So especially if you're dealing with large taxpayers, this is closely being monitored.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the subsequent slide, we presented this one
[SPEAKER_01]: there's an update on the required information for you to be able to claim the input access.
[SPEAKER_01]: So for as long as the file, the middle, the amount of sales, the 12% VAT, the registered name and team of the seller and the purchaser, the date of the transaction, and the description of the transaction are properly presented in the VAT invoice, you may already claim the input VAT on the transaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: You will note that business style is no longer necessary.
[SPEAKER_01]: And for import tax purposes, even the address of your customer or of the companies no longer necessary.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just the disfied information.
[SPEAKER_01]: Moving on to the next one.
[SPEAKER_01]: This one, just a reminder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Essentially it appears that in terms of timing it with the earlier.
[SPEAKER_01]: between the accrual or recording as an expense or asset in the books and the issuance of the sales document by the seller.
[SPEAKER_01]: So parang essentially there is no change in terms of the timing of withholding.
[SPEAKER_01]: The good thing here is if in case that you fail to withhold or there is an under withholding, it's no longer necessary for income tax purposes.
[SPEAKER_01]: But then again, as a withholding agent, that's a separate obligation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because if you fail to withhold on certain transactions, you will still be liable to deficiency withholding tax and penalties.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this new rule applies starting January 1, 2024 onwards.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, for instance, in your 2023 tax audit, it's still possible that the VIR will raise an issue on this possible disallowance as a result of non-withholding or under withholding.
[SPEAKER_05]: But for, let's say, for 2023, parang may possible disallowance.
[SPEAKER_05]: Di ba, allowed din na as long as they assess you on the withholding tax?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yup.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the remedy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, real pa rin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so for 2023 and prior years, provided that you pay the deficiency withholding tax plus the penalties, you can claim the deduction.
[SPEAKER_05]: And this one,
[SPEAKER_05]: Like say now is 2024 no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Say December 2024.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wala pa sa aming yung invoices ng 4 December ng mga suppliers namin.
[SPEAKER_05]: So when do we withhold?
[SPEAKER_05]: And when do we claim the input back?
[SPEAKER_01]: In terms of the withholding, if you actually accrue, most likely ACV will require you to accrue and these are
[SPEAKER_01]: more or less accruable even for tax purposes so you are strictly speaking applying the rules you are already required to be told that's one number two in terms of the info tax since it's for December transaction strictly speaking you should already be reported in your Q4 PET return for this period probably as a practical approach my advice is
[SPEAKER_01]: especially for recurring transactions if it's possible to get in advance the supporting invoice from your suppliers that would be helpful but if it's not provided that there's a description that it actually pertains to December transaction that will be another way to
[SPEAKER_01]: to be used as a basis for the reporting or BAT process.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's also possible that if the invoice will be dated January, there will be that question on whether you will be able to claim that as input BAT or not in your queue for reporting.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what's important is one, if it's possible to get that early.
[SPEAKER_01]: In some clients, they request the support that is
[SPEAKER_01]: Last week of December if it's possible.
[SPEAKER_01]: Especially for recurring transactions.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if it's not, January but there's really a clear description that it pertains to December transaction.
[SPEAKER_05]: But for the latter, there's that risk that it may be questioned by the VR.
[SPEAKER_05]: Anong due date ang withholding, expanded?
[SPEAKER_05]: Say December?
[SPEAKER_05]: January 31.
[SPEAKER_05]: 31.
[SPEAKER_05]: So medyo pwede pa.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mas madali yun.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ano ano?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung input bot mukhang yun yung medyo kasi new low eh.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, we have to see then how they will assess the client or the taxpayer sa result of this new low.
[SPEAKER_01]: But as a matter of practical approach, yun yung pwede natin ma-consider.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sige.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this one, just a reminder, business style is no longer necessary.
[SPEAKER_01]: Retention period, it was reduced to 5 years.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if you're using manual or loose slip, dapat hard copies.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're using computerized accounting system, you may retain electronic copies.
[SPEAKER_01]: So again, this applies 2024 onwards.
[SPEAKER_01]: For 2023 and prior years, unfortunately, it's still 10 years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Although we have this 5-year period, it's also advisable even for those using computerized accounting system to retain the hard copies for at least the next 3 years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because we've seen during tax audit that they still request for the hardcops.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hopefully eventually the BIR will have an update on their approach given this particular rule.
[SPEAKER_05]: Would you know wala pa kasi nag-laffi na shortness pasaka?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano kasi yung in terms of kanbawa may refund,
[SPEAKER_01]: In terms of failure to file, fraud cases, ang BIR can audit for 10 years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually ang 10 years from the date of discovery.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they are saying na actually it's in favor of the taxpayer din lalo na kung may mga ganoong cases na possible na ma-allege sa taxpayer.
[SPEAKER_01]: so from 10 years at least at least we're in the right direction if i may say five years tala ngayon baka eventually it may be lower next will be uh this one this one i mentioned earlier the the new loss but this one is a bir issue one so rmc5-2020 438-2024
[SPEAKER_01]: It covers the ACES case.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a Supreme Court decision.
[SPEAKER_01]: So in the slide, we presented the highlights of the case.
[SPEAKER_01]: But ultimately, in terms of the interpretation of the VIR, especially during VIR audit, their default or general position now is for as long as the services are actually consumed by a Philippine taxpayer,
[SPEAKER_01]: the general assumption is it should already be subject to final withholding tax and withholding ban.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, in the subsequent slide, we highlighted as well the clarifications made by the VIR, particularly in light of RMC number 382024.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, it's a long case
[SPEAKER_01]: But basically, they use this cases case as a basis for their approach in terms of BIR audits.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's why in terms of our transactions with non-residents, it's important that we really take a detailed review or
[SPEAKER_01]: a detailed approach in terms of reviewing the documents that will include the agreement as well as the supporting documents issued by the suppliers then after we evaluate the actual substance or nature of the transaction we'll see whether we can apply of course under the tax code if the services are entirely rendered outside the Philippines the rule is simple before
[SPEAKER_01]: it should not be subject to final withholding tax and even for 12% withholding validity.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, with this RMC, that's already the position taken by the VIR and on the part of the taxpayer, it's important for us to be ready on how we'll be able to argue otherwise.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, that's why now they are looking at the agreements if there are
[SPEAKER_01]: an excess to the agreement that will be included.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will not be surprised if in the 2023 tax audit, they will request for the agreements, the an excess, sample supporting documents especially if these are material transaction and or recurring transactions.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you will note in the slide, it includes tourism and hospitality services, the international service provision that is actually covered
[SPEAKER_01]: in the RMC that was released by the BIR.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, just for your information, we have several clients now especially those dealing with non-residents especially those with material transactions.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are engaged in terms of the review of the agreements and
[SPEAKER_01]: ang mga mga mga mga mga mga mga mga mga mga mga mga
[SPEAKER_01]: In terms of the request for confirmation, it will only cover income tax or the final withholding tax.
[SPEAKER_01]: For VAT, especially with the subsequent slide, the VAT on digital services, as mentioned earlier, this was passed into law last month.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it took effect last month.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the regulator are already working on implementing rules and regulations.
[SPEAKER_01]: But basically, it says that
[SPEAKER_01]: For digital services consumed in the Philippines, this will already be subject to 12% withholding payment.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in the slide, we presented the items included in the law itself.
[SPEAKER_01]: So those digital services that are processed through online search engine, through online marketplace or electronic marketplace, cloud service, online media and advertising,
[SPEAKER_01]: online platform or digital goods so digital goods has not been defined in the law but it's it will be defined in the IRR and our expectation is it will almost cover all transactions with non-resident except those that are clearly exempt from BAT such as those services rendered by banks and or non-bank financial intermediaries those
[SPEAKER_01]: Involving online courses, seminars, and trainings, and sale of online subscription-based services provided that these are duly accredited by the CHED, DeafAid, and similar organizations.
[SPEAKER_06]: So hindi ka-samar, Jennie?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or Netflix?
[SPEAKER_01]: Netflix, Spotify, yan.
[SPEAKER_01]: For sure, that will be covered by this new law.
[SPEAKER_01]: So actually that's the last item in terms of the tax updates.
[SPEAKER_01]: So marami, busy sila ngayon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Our lawmakers.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, hindi ko pa nashare yung what we call BEPS.
[SPEAKER_01]: But ano naman yan?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's something na at least for now significant to multinational corporations.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that's another one that
[SPEAKER_05]: that is being studied by our regulators, particularly the Department of Finance and the Bureau of Internal Revenue.
[SPEAKER_05]: So going back to our 2023 na audit nila, yun nga, doon is dapat nagbighold kami ng mga income tax and VAT for these forex players.
[SPEAKER_05]: So if they disallow, do we still have that remedy to pay for the income tax and all?
[SPEAKER_01]: For income tax, we still have that remedy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So okay pa tayo sa income tax kahit pa walang EOPT.
[SPEAKER_01]: So bayaran lang natin deficiency with holding tax plus the penalties.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay tayo for income tax.
[SPEAKER_01]: For 2023.
[SPEAKER_01]: For 2024, hindi na siya magmamatter.
[SPEAKER_01]: So kahit pa hindi na we doldan,
[SPEAKER_01]: Di naman na siya requirement for income tax.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ang major concern will be yung withholding tax talaga.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung final withholding tax and yung withholding pad.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yung final withholding tax kasi for services, that's 25% na generally denated act siya sa transaction, sa pinabayad natin sa non-resident.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless meron tayong agreement na
[SPEAKER_05]: It will be shouldered by the non-resident foreign corporation, generally.
[SPEAKER_01]: So gross up.
[SPEAKER_01]: So baka 100 talaga yung babayaran sa kanila.
[SPEAKER_01]: 100 babayaran sa kanila.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tayo yung magsosolder ng 25.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos the 25 will be remitted to the BIR.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then the 25 will be magpuporm part naman ng expense natin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pero ano siya, yung natin benefit natin is 25% lang of the 25.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kasi it will form part of our deduction.
[SPEAKER_01]: The thing is, ang laki na nga nung CWDs natin palaki nang palaki.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos I understand may null ko tayo.
[SPEAKER_01]: So ano lang talaga siya, ang impact niya is cash flow talaga sa atin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unlike kasi yung ibang kumpanyat, okay lang sila sa ganun kasi malaki naman talaga yung tax payable nila.
[SPEAKER_01]: at least to some extent, mayroon sinang benefit yung 25% nung additional ng tax na sinuswinter nila.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if in case naman will take the position na hindi dapat to subject, it will require talaga detailed look over the agreements, the sample supporting documents.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if necessary, baka we need to explore
[SPEAKER_01]: Using the tax treaty provision kung meron tax treaty.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mostly U.S.
[SPEAKER_05]: yung ano namin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ayun po.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meron po tayong RPUS tax treaty.
[SPEAKER_01]: So titiknan po natin yung conditions ng tax treaty kung makokomply po natin siya.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then, magsasubmit tayo ng request for confirmation with all the necessary documents.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then, a pan-review ni BIR kung masabi niya na talagang they are compliant with the conditions as per tax treaty, they will issue what we call certificate of entitlement, proving na yung transaction is exempt from the final bid only.
[SPEAKER_07]: So kung yun yung parang... Ano na tawag dito?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yung sa TAPS treaty?
[SPEAKER_07]: Sorry, sorry.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kung may remedy... Pwede pa ba yan i-remedy by telling them na, ito yung deficiency ninyo sa foreign suppliers and then can you make a contract that exists?
[SPEAKER_07]: Even if na-assess kami ngayon, pero yung future,
[SPEAKER_07]: At least para hindi na magkaroon ng deficiency ulit, pwede na nang yamend yung contract to be compliant?
[SPEAKER_01]: Pwede naman siya pero generally ang application is prospective.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then another one is, dati kasi no, pag may nakalagi ka na na the services will be entirely rendered in say US, dati they stopped there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ngayon kasi they really did
[SPEAKER_01]: on the nature of the transaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if the transaction will require say, visit here in the Philippines talaga, nabawalan ang ganun yung transaction, no?
[SPEAKER_01]: So kahit pa may ganong statement, we've seen in actual tax audits na kini-question nila, especially kung merong provision na from time to time, say from time to time there will be visits in the Philippines, kung may mga ganong provisions or any other
[SPEAKER_01]: similar provision na might be in conflict with that provision.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yun yung siguro pabantayan lang natin para lang at least mas ma-manage natin yung possible question during tax audit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And another thing is yung yun nga yung with the application of the RMC.
[SPEAKER_01]: Medyo nagiging ano kasi no general yung approach yung yung interpretation ni BIR na parang basta nandito sa Pilipinas yung
[SPEAKER_01]: yung consumer in our case tayo then they will already impose final withholding, tax and withholding but so ano lang no, just a heads up so ang mga yari na lang doon is yun niya ang mga yari will submit the contract hopefully the billings or the invoices from them na nakalagay talaga na say the services are rendered in US or any other country outside the Philippines so that will help naman nakita namin but there are also cases na dependent talaga dun sa
[SPEAKER_01]: nature ng transaksyon kahit pa may ganun, kinachallenge pa rin nila especially yung talagang tingin nila where there are other documents
[SPEAKER_01]: that will prove na mayroon nagpinita dito eh.
[SPEAKER_01]: So kung ganun talaga yung nangyari naman, ang normal na nagiging advice namin sa cliente namin is to file a request for confirmation para at least hindi na tax code yung pangahawakan mong basis for the non-withholding but rather the tax treaty na.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sa tax treaty kasi, generally,
[SPEAKER_01]: 6 months or 183 days.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kung hindi ka mag-exceed naman dito, then pwede nilang sabihin na walang permanent establishment and therefore walang final withholding tax na dapat iimpose.
[SPEAKER_07]: So yung mga parang ongoing contacts sa amin na hindi walang end date, that's considered kasi nga
[SPEAKER_07]: Halos yung mga contracts namin, ano 1995 ganyan.
[SPEAKER_07]: Mahababa eh.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yun kasi defender rin sa probation ng tax treaty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meron kasi ang tax treaty na ang pagbibilang nila ng 183 days or 6 months per fiscal year or per calendar year.
[SPEAKER_01]: So mayroon din namang tax treaty na talagang continues.
[SPEAKER_01]: So kahit pa 1995 yan, kung mayroon ka ng ma-determine nila, for some reason kung anong procedure nila, masasabi nila na in the entire duration of the contract mayroon na-breached na yung 6 months or the 183-day period generally, then they will say that there is actually a permanent establishment and therefore even with the tax treaty,
[SPEAKER_01]: You are subject to... That particular transaction is subject to final withholding tax.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, magdindepende sa wording din ng tax treaty.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sa ano yan?
[SPEAKER_05]: Where do you secure itong confirmation sa special unit na naman ng PIR?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sa International Tax Appears Division of the Bureau of Internal Revenue.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sa ITAL.
[SPEAKER_01]: So ano siya, it's... Kung ang mga iyari is... Hindi mo siya we withhold dan, for instance, ang gagawin natin is request for confirmation.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that will be request for confirmation, tapos may mga dokumento siya na kailangan.
[SPEAKER_01]: It includes the agreement and some other supporting documents.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ang ibang cases naman, ang nangyari is bibitultan natin.
[SPEAKER_01]: So ibig sabihin conservative yung ating position.
[SPEAKER_01]: So si non-resident naman, sasabihin niya, hindi entitled kami to the treaty benefits.
[SPEAKER_01]: So ang mga yari naman, hindi na request for confirmation.
[SPEAKER_01]: ang tawag na is that tax treaty relief application.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, sasabihin naman doon is, oh, tama nga, hindi nga siya subject.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, mangyari, kung confirm siya ni BIR, then ang next stage will be magpafile ng refund for the amount na naweigh held doon sa transaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, depende siya kung ano yung matiting approach natin.
[SPEAKER_01]: But then again, reminder ko lang, this covers income tax or on your side, it's the final withholding tax.
[SPEAKER_05]: It does not extend to value added tax or the withholding meaning.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, assuming na paglabas nitong IRR ito, then may mga conditions ba doon na, if not more than 3M ang parang income, diba, ng COVID Corporation.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ano yun?
[SPEAKER_05]: We need to ask from them a certification na hindi sila mag-exit ng 3M.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung ano kasi, well at least based on the law itself, yung 3 million kasi, it's critical for the registration of the non-resident.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if they will breach the 3 million, they are required to register for VAT purposes and therefore they are required to file their own bat return.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pero sa side natin, as customer, Philippine-based customer, whether or not registered sila,
[SPEAKER_01]: For as long as it's covered by the law, digital services consumed in the Philippines natin, then we are required to withhold 12% withholding.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, ano lang naman siya?
[SPEAKER_01]: In and out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ang withholding path kasi is, generally it's on top.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's say 100 plus 12.
[SPEAKER_01]: so wala talaga tayong ibabawas sa kanila then GAT 12 will form part of our input tax naman sa regular piling natin ng BAT return then again ano bang BAT payable position ba tayo ngayon or excess input tax credits position?
[SPEAKER_01]: kung BAT payable naman it's a good thing kasi bayaran mo lang magagamit mo naman pabawas mo siya so at least sa BAT payable position more on may konting araw lang na para cost of money kumbaga kasi ang
[SPEAKER_01]: deadline for ringgitans of the withholding back is on the 10th, following the end of the month.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then we can report that as input back on our regular filing of the back return.
[SPEAKER_07]: So looks like as of now based on the input that we have, yung final withholding tax talaga yung we need to take a look at it.
[SPEAKER_07]: Balikak ko lang siya sinabi mo kanilig na yung sa withholding, you can apply for refund.
[SPEAKER_07]: yung pag-iil nila for it.
[SPEAKER_07]: Does that mean you initially pay?
[SPEAKER_07]: So hindi pa rin makukuha?
[SPEAKER_01]: Practical, practical.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano naman kasi siya?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's typical kung ang iyong non-resident na supplier, hindi mo apili.
[SPEAKER_01]: So kung hindi mo siya apili, and talaga nakikita namin ito eh, conservative talaga yung Philippine based customer, they will withhold.
[SPEAKER_01]: kasasabiya nila yung kanilang supplier o supplier kung gusto mong ano yan, isubject yan sa treaty provision, tax treaty really publication tayo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos kapag na-confirm, refund mo yan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pero meron din naman, I should say, in terms of their discussion as part of business consideration, sige supplier, di kita wiwi doldan, ha?
[SPEAKER_01]: Pero kailangan ko mag-secrete ng request for confirmation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kailangan lahat ng dokumento na kailangan ipasa for that application.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ibigay mo sa akin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Para at least, pag sinabig ko yan kay BIR, pag aaralan nila yan, kapag pinaprobaan ni BIR yan, walang tayong problema.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kasi ako magkakaproblema kapag di ako nag-vidun tapos wala akong ganyan.
[SPEAKER_01]: At least sa BIR level kasi.
[SPEAKER_01]: E, syempre tayo naman, since si BIR mag-audit sa atin, and kaya kung kaya naman natin mag-comply,
[SPEAKER_07]: It's advisable talaga.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: May isa pang question.
[SPEAKER_01]: Client kasi namin ng ADB, what is it considered as?
[SPEAKER_01]: Adb?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, ADB ah, Asian Development Office.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think may local offices.
[SPEAKER_07]: Meron, hindi nga yun nga yung local.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, kasi nga marami sinang foreign rent personnel, di ba?
[SPEAKER_07]: Pero kasi kung si ADB naman na binabayar natin as a local entity.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, dalawa sila kasi yung iba literature yung iba consultant.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, I just want to understand kung ano ang, ano kasi nga ang consultant, what do we mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: Consultants ng ADB na foreigners, what do we mean?
[SPEAKER_07]: Separate siya sa ADB?
[SPEAKER_07]: Oo.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi ang dina- Sorry.
[SPEAKER_07]: Minsa kasi sila yung binibigyan na sa kanila yung
[SPEAKER_01]: money nila yung ganoon so siguro first things first sino ba ang kakontrata natin pag ganoon ang case?
[SPEAKER_07]: yung minsan pinara yung passenger hindi yung in terms of the transaction with the consultant siya na kasi nga binigay yung money sa kanya siya anong transaction natin?
[SPEAKER_01]: minsan kasi income payment ba yung
[SPEAKER_07]: Hindi, iyan papasok.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, and then... Ano to, yung... We also pay a GSA na nasa labas ng bansa.
[SPEAKER_07]: Parang ganun.
[SPEAKER_07]: I just want to understand yung magiging relationship niya.
[SPEAKER_07]: Na... Kasi foreigner siya.
[SPEAKER_07]: Nagbayad sa amin.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ah, nagbayad sa inyo?
[SPEAKER_07]: Aso customer siya?
[SPEAKER_07]: Customer siya.
[SPEAKER_07]: Tapos nung nagbayad kami to a... a... ano man?
[SPEAKER_07]: Kuya na rin, agency nila.
[SPEAKER_07]: Abroad.
Abroad for the services.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, is there anything we need to withhold?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, at least for this purpose kung customer natin siya, okay lang tayo ito.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ngunang issue.
[SPEAKER_07]: Offensive customer that we are ordering something from outside.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ayan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yan, that... Well, I can't say categorically right now, but it will depend on the agreement.
[SPEAKER_01]: But RMC, the RMC earlier, by specifically, there's that risk.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's that risk that it will be subject to the final bidonding tax and even bidonding BID.
[SPEAKER_01]: So for widowning BAT, it may be further strengthened by the Baton Digital Services once the IRR is released.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the possibility.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's also possible that in the IRR, it will be clear that it's not subject or it's not covered.
[SPEAKER_01]: But with the RMC, specifically 5-2024, there's that risk especially given our experience in the Baris BIR audience right now.
[SPEAKER_05]: So wala nang makakatravel na, no?
[SPEAKER_05]: Locals and foreigners, if we add up itong anong, pang-holding, na-payments sa operators, sa frauds, kasi we have to consider, yung parang i-add namin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, nakita ko nga parang, I think si Netflix or Spotify atan, karoon na nang increase agad na notice sa, di ko alam isa sa kanila,
[SPEAKER_01]: may notice na nag-increase na sila, siguro anticipating the impact of the ban on digital services.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yun, nakikita namin from what we saw, meron mga conservative talaga, nagwiwinod na, meron din naman talagang using the tax code provisions since these are services rendered outside the Philippines.
[SPEAKER_01]: They will really argue na hindi siya subject, but of course in terms of tax audit, it's important that we'll be able to provide the necessary documentation, agreement, invoices, billings, and any other documents to prove our position.
[SPEAKER_01]: Third will be the application of the tax duty insofar as FWT or income tax is concerned.
[SPEAKER_01]: So may mga nag-explore ng kanong avenue.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yun lang, just sharing the options.
[SPEAKER_05]: So would you know like if there are...
[SPEAKER_05]: Clients that are already asking, even without HIRR, if they are already asking their foreign suppliers, what will be their position?
[SPEAKER_01]: Even without the ban on digital services, there are already clients taking the conservative position to withhold in light of the RMCs.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, there are.
[SPEAKER_01]: But meron na ring, meron pa ring clients na, eto kasi ang tax code probation naman.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kung wala naman talagang services and they are confident that they will be able to prove that, then no withholding yung ginagawa nila.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung iba, yun, exploring another option, in addition to the tax code probation, they will make use of the tax treaty probation.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that will entail a filing of the request for confirmation as I mentioned earlier.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pag-a-blog na lang tayo franchise ng Marina Sanya.
[SPEAKER_07]: O Adox.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi kasi airlines alone, they're subject to percentage tax.
[SPEAKER_07]: Dapat.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pero ngayon, dahil tayo yung
[SPEAKER_07]: gumibili na ng airline on behalf of the clients.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi there's a different collecting company, Ayata.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ayata doesn't provide, has no provision for vat nor with hoodie.
[SPEAKER_07]: So what's the position that the airlines are giving?
[SPEAKER_00]: Wala siya eh.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're discussing siya kay Ayata.
[SPEAKER_07]: O kasi nga malabuh yan eh.
[SPEAKER_07]: They all have their offices here, but they're subject to percentage tax.
[SPEAKER_07]: Eh kami yung bumibili sa kanila, alam naman naman kami may withholding may VAT on something that doesn't have VAT.
[SPEAKER_07]: So paan yan, e iba-iba rin yung ano nila yung
[SPEAKER_07]: bilateral agreements nila, it's not the same.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pala sa different taxation than the other airlines.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, paano rin yun?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yung ganoon?
[SPEAKER_07]: Ano naman, ma-iintindi ko lalat yun.
[SPEAKER_07]: Paano naman?
[SPEAKER_01]: Talaga ba?
[SPEAKER_01]: Baka mahihan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung iba kasi, meron talaga, like with the Yopitino ECB, the realistic industry, meron talaga silang naging dialogue with the VIR.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I understand baka karoon ng RMC to be released specifically for their industry.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've seen one for the power industry, tapos may palabas for construction.
[SPEAKER_01]: So baka this is something kung talaga namang ano siya, it's because of the industry, something na... Baka pwedeng i-ano, no?
[SPEAKER_07]: Si Elyata and yung ano...
[SPEAKER_07]: Yun.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kaya na inaano nila na I fix the position paper.
[SPEAKER_07]: But the thing is, not all agencies are corporations.
[SPEAKER_07]: Mas marami yung hindi corporations in the first place.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I'm trying to put it together na it's just the Ayata agents, which is just about 200, considering that there are 10,000 agents.
[SPEAKER_07]: So it's a minority but that's the volume.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yung 200 na yun.
[SPEAKER_07]: Those are the ones with the volume.
[SPEAKER_07]: So medyo, nahihihirapan ako.
[SPEAKER_07]: And ay atas, partially been healthy with certain things.
[SPEAKER_09]: But not on yun nga yung sa widodi.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi yung percentage tax siya.
[SPEAKER_09]: So parang ang hirap isip din.
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang same with sa power.
[SPEAKER_09]: Meron din silang parang iyakta yung ay...
[SPEAKER_09]: IOM ba yun?
[SPEAKER_09]: Basta meron ni sinang gano, may clearing ano sila.
[SPEAKER_09]: IOM, I forgot.
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka yun nga yung... Tignan natin.
[SPEAKER_09]: Baka dapat ano, diba?
[SPEAKER_09]: May alignment na dito.
[SPEAKER_09]: You may want to also ano.
[SPEAKER_09]: Syempre dapat ayayosin niyo muna yung position niyo before.
[SPEAKER_01]: You go to VIR, diba?
[SPEAKER_01]: At this point, hindi advisable muna kay VIR.
[SPEAKER_01]: Siguro as at least the top players, you gather.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ganun ginawa ng iba't industries.
[SPEAKER_01]: They gather.
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang real to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano nang nangyari talaga?
[SPEAKER_01]: What we do before disissuance?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano bang ginagawa namin?
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos they discuss, okay, aligned na mong pala tayo.
[SPEAKER_01]: But with disissuance, ano bang concern natin?
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos they will take that, with this one we understand the rationale but here's the thing, ito yung siguro difficulty in the implementation, etc.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then may mga position paper as an organization.
[SPEAKER_01]: They request for confirmation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meron din na kami nakita na parang deferral.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kung pwede, at least man lang.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kung di talaga pwedeng entirely, hindi applicable sa inyo, pwede bang deferral man lang?
[SPEAKER_10]: Give us time to implement yung mga ganas.
[SPEAKER_07]: So you have that service na to check our contract?
[SPEAKER_01]: We actually do it with our tax advisory team.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kasi kami sa tax compliance team.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we combine it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang several clients na kasi namin siya nagawa.
[SPEAKER_01]: So nagiging two phases siya.
[SPEAKER_01]: First phase is the tunalagang review of the contract, the agreement, what are the options available.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then the second phase will be the implementation phase.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dun nga papasok yung magpapayal ng request for confirmation, to strengthen our position, and kung ano pa yung mga pwedeng gawin.
[SPEAKER_07]: So if we engage, sino susulata naman?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we can discuss internally na.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually earlier ganito rin yung pinag-ugusapan namin sa another client.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ganun din, marami rin sila.
[SPEAKER_01]: In their case naman puro happy leads kasi naman yung kanila.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mas lalong sa kanila crucial kasi whether may impact sa kanila sa Philippine entity or wala,
[SPEAKER_01]: Mababawasan mo yung babayaran mo dun sa appellate mo ha, Brod.
[SPEAKER_01]: So globally, tatamaan sila.
[SPEAKER_01]: So kaya kailangan talaga may strengthen yung position.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mag-sandwich mo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mag-sandwich mo na.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pasensiyan na.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not so good news at least on that one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ano parang position niyo?
[SPEAKER_05]: Parang hindi na is a doing business?
[SPEAKER_05]: For the pastayers?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano ng mix naman?
[SPEAKER_01]: Kasi naman siyang portion na hindi na highlight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like sa mga battery fund claims kasi medyo nagstreamline talaga ng process and the required documents.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos another thing yun ya, yung natanggal yung requirement to withhold para maging deductible.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung pinawasan yung required information para maklaim mo yung input funds.
[SPEAKER_01]: So medyo meron pa rin ang positive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, mas na-highlight yung mga medyo not so good.
[SPEAKER_05]: Globally, nakita ko rin ang Netflix, ita-tax na rin sa Europe.
[SPEAKER_07]: Basta na talaga ang stream pa na rin all, kasi makaka-akas yung Netflix.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ang inisip lang nila yung, siyempre lahat nang nakikita nila, mga stream.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pero hindi na.
[SPEAKER_07]: Maraming transactions na yung team, ganun ka straight forward.
[SPEAKER_07]: O kasi ngayon, like the hotels, they're all in the GDS.
[SPEAKER_07]: We don't have a contract with them.
[SPEAKER_07]: We just have a contract with their aggregator.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, paano mo naman siya ita-tax eh hindi naman kami nagbubok doon?
[SPEAKER_07]: We're just looking through the aggregator.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, parang umlabo, yung ganun.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pag sila nito ba?
[SPEAKER_07]: Like, aggoda yan?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yung aggregator ba yun?
[SPEAKER_07]: Isa yan sa mga aggregators, but that's more of a B2C platform kasi.
[SPEAKER_07]: Meron kasi yung tinatawag na general distribution system, that that computer collates all the different contracts with everyone in the world, which is used everywhere in the world.
[SPEAKER_07]: So dahil nga with that kind of a set up, yun ang ginagamit namin na system, yung ganun.
[SPEAKER_07]: So doon namin kinukoya umatala, yun lang naman lahat ng hotel na kuni namin doon.
[SPEAKER_09]: Meron kaming, alam nyo, it's impossible.
[SPEAKER_09]: It's impossible.
[SPEAKER_09]: Parang hindi na pag-isipan.
[SPEAKER_09]: Parang ganun.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi nga ngayon, the how we do business ang iba na eh, diba?
[SPEAKER_09]: Oo.
[SPEAKER_09]: But yun nga, yung regulations, medyo... Well, mayroon na siyang digital pero... yun yung reservation system kasi natin.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's just we're touching a reservation system.
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_07]: Wala naman.
[SPEAKER_07]: We don't deal directly.
[SPEAKER_07]: We don't deal directly with all the hotels in the world.
[SPEAKER_07]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_07]: They only have the inventory of it.
[SPEAKER_07]: Dahil nga nakita namin, yung gubot namin yun.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's not anymore like a one on one.
[SPEAKER_07]: Malabo eh.
[SPEAKER_07]: Parang naroon.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yun yung hindi nila nag-get na portion siguro.
[SPEAKER_07]: We'll see how it goes.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi at least kung power, mayroon siyang
[SPEAKER_07]: cleaning house.
[SPEAKER_09]: It's just for power.
[SPEAKER_07]: Like an airline at saka dapat ang taxable portion ngayon.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's just the first leg of the journey eh.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi may bayabaya points eh yung ganon.
[SPEAKER_06]: Ok na.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ok na.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nagutom ako dito sa... Wait niya ng common na reply sa akin.
[SPEAKER_07]: Parang nagagutom naman natinis kasi.
[SPEAKER_07]: So ito, may kasalanan.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't shoot the messenger now.
Shoot it on the next one.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hindi, kapyan na lang yung lawmakers.
[SPEAKER_07]: Para maingin din yung nakikina na ng kresyo habang tumata siya exchange rate.
[SPEAKER_10]: Pero pang nakikin si mga suppliers natin ay namin kasi namin operators.
[SPEAKER_08]: Kasi mas maganda na e, no?
[SPEAKER_10]: Sa ating nga, yung mga kanon yung... Kasi mga operators natin, e. Mabawa, nilalala.
[SPEAKER_08]: E, hindi i-attack, kasi sila muna kasi naman.
[SPEAKER_08]: Naka siya, Japan.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yung operator ang gano'y nalaman ang contact, yun.
[SPEAKER_08]: Ngunod naman tali siya, tapos tayo sa kanilang brand.
[SPEAKER_08]: Pwede naman pretend, no?
[SPEAKER_08]: Pwede.
[SPEAKER_08]: Pero on top.
[SPEAKER_08]: Pwede sabihin niya, no?
[SPEAKER_08]: Mike, no?
[SPEAKER_08]: I-in piece.
[SPEAKER_08]: Parang mag-rather din na, ande yata.
[SPEAKER_08]: Pala, entindihan, and then, if you want us to help, then at least ande na sila.
[SPEAKER_08]: Tama namin yung ano, yung isang tax lawyer.
[SPEAKER_07]: O dami ito tako ne.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pati yung credit card ne, yung wala pa phone present.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano niya?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano yun?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ano yung cash ko talaga?
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang narinig ko dyan.
[SPEAKER_01]: May discussion even before the pandemic about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang seeking clarification on the tax base.
[SPEAKER_01]: Di pala natuloy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, I'm waiting for update dyan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang may initial discussion with the BIR daw.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi nga yung cash flow ay understand, yun yung tok-tok.
[SPEAKER_07]: Nung ano pa yan, nung time ni Russellis pa yan, na we were doing the tax position paper at that time na hindi yung natuloy yun.
[SPEAKER_07]: But that was the only official document that was out there.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pero alam ko, there were initial talks with
[SPEAKER_07]: Sino na nga yung ex-SGB na nandon noon noon ng panaman ni Kimenares?
[SPEAKER_08]: Panaman pa yun ni Kimenares every time?
[SPEAKER_08]: Yung mga sa EDB na?
[SPEAKER_08]: Si ano nga na yung... Yung Joel.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ay!
[SPEAKER_07]: At ano?
Joel.
[SPEAKER_08]: Ayaw ko sabihan.
[SPEAKER_08]: Bakit?
[SPEAKER_08]: Yung Joel Tantor.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hindi.
[SPEAKER_05]: Baka eh.
Siya ba?
Oo yata.
Oo na.
Di ba nag-D.I.R.
yun?
Then napuntang last na, well, I don't know kung madumpa sa E.D., di pa walang.
Hindi ko na alam saan siya na yun.
Oo.
Aning yung part ng U.P.
U.P.
Exactly.
system.
Parang yata eh.
[SPEAKER_08]: So bako muna ka siya, no?
[SPEAKER_07]: Ako ba ako si Chancellor?
[SPEAKER_07]: Parang... Parang hindi siya nang... Parang hindi siya, no?
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi kung na nga yung two girls na kasama niya,
[SPEAKER_07]: Bajesa, talag.
[SPEAKER_07]: Nakaasal na.
[SPEAKER_07]: Baka na sa photo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Si Karol, Roselis, tapos si Vanny, Ewan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ayun, Vanny.
[SPEAKER_01]: At tapos may isa ba?
[SPEAKER_01]: Steph?
[SPEAKER_01]: Steph na ba?
[SPEAKER_01]: O yun, si Steph.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nandito pa rin siya, di ba?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sa indirect tax namin, si Steph.
[SPEAKER_01]: si Carol is a business taxor business.
[SPEAKER_07]: We talked to her recently kasi nga yang ANA na airline and also United Airlines.
[SPEAKER_07]: Those are the only two that are withholding on commission.
[SPEAKER_07]: Pero kasi all the rest are reporting on net from the airline.
[SPEAKER_07]: So yun.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I'm just trying to talk to them kasi it never existed na
[SPEAKER_07]: We acknowledge that we have commission dahil nga we have transaction fee with the client.
[SPEAKER_07]: So paano kami magkakaroon ng commission?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yung ganon.
[SPEAKER_07]: Isang magulo rin yun kasi sino ba yung, kanino ba kami kumuha ng income so to speak?
[SPEAKER_07]: It's with the client eh.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm halfway with Ayatta kasi they have a column now in their reporting that says supplier discount of Indiana supplier commission so pero kasi it's not open to the Philippines yung column na yun so I'm trying to find out how to open that column that particular column so that the airlines will also report on net mas mababa rin yung
[SPEAKER_07]: babayaran nilang tax, diba?
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi nga, it's not anymore on the gross.
[SPEAKER_07]: The gross is meant to be there just as a filing with ano naman, DOTR, nung mga fares nila.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kasi they also have to put the fares in the GPS na ginagamit namin dahil nga globally nila binibigay.
[SPEAKER_07]: So the others are on commission, others are on net base.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, doon,
[SPEAKER_07]: So, the term commission is used very loosely in the industry.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's not really a commission tool, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sabi ko nga, pag dinin man ang GAR, basa sa kanila, it's commission.
Commission.
And it's a term in our industry.
[SPEAKER_07]: Parang ganun.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's a different... ano...
[SPEAKER_07]: tapos lahat yun global template so they cannot just change here to suit our Philippine needs na napakalingit ng market yung parang ganun as compared to Europe, US yung ganun iba eh
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll see what are the next steps after this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crucial yung kayo mismo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have that alignment in terms of what you do now and what will you do as a result.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mabilis pa lang ang pagkain mo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ma-address or na?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yun yung within 6 months naman.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nakita namin recently, within 6 months nakakasagot naman.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we'll see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Depende rin kasi sa peculiarity ng income payment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kung pretty straightforward naman, mas mabilis pa.
[SPEAKER_01]: At least within that 6 month period.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tapability pa ang DICT ay stock yung mga services.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yung lang, no?
[SPEAKER_05]: E yun lang mga dito.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mga products, mga diwala bago ay wala silang budget, e yan pa.
[SPEAKER_09]: Dato na, Mike.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ang nag-increase ng rate yung YouTube premium.
Ah, YouTube premium.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sunod-sunod na yan.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, they're not here.
[SPEAKER_07]: What's yung individual consumers?
Tayo na naman, no?
Tadaga, papasarin din ng... Sa atin din ang paray.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sino nagatin doon sa angchang na, ano?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sino nagatin sa angchang na... Speaker?
...tag-a-SGB?
De Jos po, asa.
Ah, si Victor De Jos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Siya kasi nag-eat samin sa discussions ng Bandot Digital Services.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, mayroon siyang column sa business world about the impact of Bandot Digital Services.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sinong technical working group pa yan ng BIR sa IR?
[SPEAKER_05]: Nakalimutan ko yung name, but we have a contact with them.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ang alam ko, they will soon have a public consultation about the contents of the drama IR.
[SPEAKER_05]: When you mean public consultation?
[SPEAKER_05]: Open to all.
[SPEAKER_01]: usually sa amin from our side kasi we may have clients na affected so they also extend that even to the private corporations I think like the EOPT sa Facebook nila they stream that live but they also have yung parang value for face to face identities mas okay kung yung sa face to face kasi mas maikita mo sila
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus, you can directly raise your concerns or questions.
[SPEAKER_08]: Then, if not possible, at least naka-stream naman live sa Facebook page nila.
[SPEAKER_08]: Alight.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_08]: Abang may anang susunod na kabaleta.
[SPEAKER_05]: So ano yan, it will also be a part of your audit na yan na kung one compliant ang clients nyo sa audit?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I think not siguro namin, but I'm not... Strictly, no.
[SPEAKER_09]: Kasi hindi rin namin, magtanongin.
[SPEAKER_09]: Pag-a-gusyong magpatax kong clients, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Kasi ang bubulat-latit talaga nila yung... Well, in preparation din sa class, we'd most likely be doing that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, we have two ongoing projects kasi plano nga nila mag-computerize sa accounting system.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, ang nangyayari is yung inputs ng engagement namin, they will use it as part of the implementation of the CES.
[SPEAKER_01]: Para at least, like yung mga ano ba yung kulang sa substantiation, ano ba yung normally nakikita sa tax audit ni BAR na pwedeng ma-address ng mga certain changes sa process.
[SPEAKER_05]: na ginagawa especially for tax reporting, tax filing.
[SPEAKER_05]: So ganoon yung nagiging approach ng cliente.
[SPEAKER_05]: Which comes first?
[SPEAKER_05]: Parang yung guidance nyo, bago ni-present ng cliente sa inyo, naano nilang process or...
[SPEAKER_01]: Ang nangyayari isa sa ganitong engagement, we anumuna, we'll have that what we call kick-off meeting with them to further discuss yung approach namin, the timeline.
[SPEAKER_01]: Parang ganito, planning for audience.
[SPEAKER_01]: then there will be a portion na what we call they will share with us yung mga nakikita nilang possible focus areas like kung ano bang transactions natingin nila may concern sila or most likely baka merong kailangan tignan because for some possible tax concerns but kami we have that ano naman standard procedures din
[SPEAKER_01]: na we have the general procedures, tapos meron din kaming procedures na specific to the industries of our clients.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kung service industry, kung let's say meron kaming manufacturing, pharma, ganyan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Para kaming nagkakandap ng BIR audit.
[SPEAKER_07]: Na walang penalty.
[SPEAKER_07]: We'll be the few na maunakan natin siya.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ang 5 days lang, walang penalty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tapos yung iba, dahil di kasi may mga general tax amnesty.
[SPEAKER_01]: So kung yung results ng aming engagement, to the extent na quantifiable yung exposure,
[SPEAKER_01]: They will be able to use that to at least have a number in mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nabawa ang computation ng amnesty is 2% of North Korean assets.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ganyan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pag kinumpute ko yun, you will be able to avail of the amnesty for say 2023 in prior years.
[SPEAKER_01]: So ang lalapas na amount si 20 million, nabawa lang.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then, yung exposure na nakita sa tax engagement namin will be about 100 million.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, and mukhang talagang malabo na ma-depend mo yung position mo in light of the issues na ni-raise namin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung ginagawa ng client, i-avail na ni Retax Amnesty.
[SPEAKER_01]: At least it covers 2023 and prior years.
[SPEAKER_01]: As compared doon sa kumbaga parang self-assessment na rin ang cliente na P100M kung sa kaling lumabas yung talaga sa tax audit plus lalaki pa kasi yun because of the penalties.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung interest kasi lalaki.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, something na pwedeng... although right now kasi wala pa kami naririnig ng tax office din.
[SPEAKER_01]: Puro collection.
[SPEAKER_01]: New laws tax audit sabi niyo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Short live lang kasi yung ano eh, tapos gumawa rin ako.
[SPEAKER_01]: At asyado rin malaki eh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yung 2017 prior, yung glass amnesy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ay hindi ba kayo nag-avail during the time?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yun kasi po, self-assessment naman natin hindi naman aabot sa ganung ang mga talaga advisable na we avail of that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Bano yung basis nila eh.
[SPEAKER_05]: hindi ka nung ipang yung previous amnestis na talaga ayun medyo, medyo mapapang minimum lang o palo, 75, 100,000 pesos naging ano po kasi based on percentage talaga yung
[SPEAKER_01]: last na general tax havenist except for i think for small talaga ng entities na medyo papasok doon sa mababa talaga but if you're a medium to large tax payers doon ka sa percentage na malaki-laki pag kinonvert talaga kaya parang nga naman ko kakawin ang ano eh nagkabing
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.
Thank you then for coming.
Let's update each other.
[SPEAKER_06]: O kanina hindi okay dito.
[SPEAKER_08]: Pinatay ni Jon dito niya.
[SPEAKER_05]: Digital.
[SPEAKER_06]: building to no building bagay sit budget para hindi na mali tayo driver ah
[SPEAKER_05]: Pero ano ba yung... ano ba yung may last year ba na hindi ka makaabing, maka... pao sa portal, maka-approval?
Ano ba?
Ano lang, kaya kitang shoot the camera.
[SPEAKER_06]: Actually, nai-kick mo na yun.
[SPEAKER_06]: Kaya mo ng ano.
[SPEAKER_03]: Si Anong Chanelle.
[SPEAKER_02]: Si Chanelle, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: May miss siya.
[SPEAKER_04]: Salamat!
[SPEAKER_02]: Mahalo na sila.
Ay, sige po.
[SPEAKER_02]: May kailangan si Emin na tayo?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oo, sige.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sige po.
[SPEAKER_02]: Akin-sige po.
Sige po.
Akin-sige po.
[SPEAKER_06]: Akin-sige po.
[SPEAKER_02]: Akin-sige po.
Akin-sige po.
[SPEAKER_06]: Akin-sige po.
[SPEAKER_02]: Akin-sige po.